hello everyone Karen warden with Phil
Curtis radio show and I'm here with a
wonderful Deborah a curling of right on
online calm and also the radio show on
blogtalkradio blogtalk splash long talk
radio / ride on online okay because my
monthly meetings that I think I talked
about so in depth the last time we
chatted there now online so if you don't
have to be in LA to attend you can just
call it I started having guests on I had
mark Coker who founded smashwords last
week yeah last week for the much meeting
in back in February am our whose script
consultant who does the princess scribe
blog she's my guest so it gives me a
little bit more freedom but it also
allows me to involve the people who
aren't fortunate enough to live in Los
Angeles give a little extra push in the
right direction to get there okay write
down well let's go back to write on
online when did you begin it and how did
you grow if well it's the live group
started nine years ago it just went all
virtual last september's when I move
that the meetings to blog talk radio and
the website has been up for about three
and a half years and its really it's
been fun for me because that originally
I started out as okay I need a place to
put the newsletter so it here's a blog
and then a friend of mine how to book
come out wonderful i'll start doing
author interviews
I enjoyed that so much I started doing
other interviews every Tuesday and did
an outreach to some of my writing
friends and I got some more books back
and then I said why not you know open it
up more and put a query out to help a
reporter calm I got almost 400 responses
of authors yeah it's how I do it yeah
that it was well I like it because I
like to do a mix of known in
up-and-coming authors and I also do non
fiction fiction screen writers bloggers
journalists because I think it's
important for all writers to learn about
all kinds of writing it's the whole my
coaching site my personal training for
writer site is right on track a light
it's about an entire philosophy of
writing this exercise and I believe you
get the best exercise when you're doing
different kinds of workouts so writing
in different areas that's a big reason
why i'd like to showcase the different
kinds of writers so answer affecting
answering your question so I bumped it
up to interviews twice a week then I
brought in rotating expert columns on
Thursdays and then last year I added a
right on reviews so now we have mondays
is right on reviews Tuesdays are the
author cabernets wednesday is right on
wednesday which is just up and coming
events like what we did today so I don't
have to wait for the monthly newsletter
to doubt the word of the cool things
that are going on and then Thursday's
the rotating expert column in friday i'm
switching off between video interviews
and random writing prompts because i
just like to mix it up a little bit but
it's it was not a fast process I
literally did just two days a week for a
couple years and then I I saw
opportunities and I
site and once i was doing four days as
well do five so i jumped from 3 to 4
2day little monday through friday pretty
quickly but it's fun it's just all on
the name of helping writers get their
words out more and so you do all the
website made its yourself you upload all
the content that i do i do i do have as
I mentioned I've got rotating guest
columns no genie barman who was here Vic
to summer guess she does the writing
resources reviews and I've got Maria
Fotopoulos doing film reviews and
thumper Mahdi and he does the TV reviews
and Phillip is in Georgia ingenious in
New York and Maria's in Los Angeles so
it's also different different parts of
the country you know it's it's great i
love internet you don't have to be here
to get the word out about what you're
doing and I like encouraging people at
different stages so which what would you
say to someone that wants to start a
website of some type doesn't have to be
necessarily for writers or filmmakers
but what would you say to that person as
far as the type of time they're going to
have to commit and how they put out
queries to the possible writers wow
that's like one of my favorite questions
because it's one of the things that I
teaches marketing to blogging and social
networking the first thing I say is
don't overwhelm yourself and I said
several times the last week when I was
in Austin it's the biggest problem
people have rather the biggest mistake
people have is they get so overwhelmed
by the prospect of doing a website or a
blog they just don't do it and so the
real secret is you want to commit to one
day a week I like Tuesdays I I think
there is also research that shows but
that's the best day of the week to post
and then
I don't wanna you can start with blog
posts of 300 to 500 words I know people
who write a lot more than that and I
think that's great if they can do it but
if you're short on time and you're just
starting out don't overwhelm yourself do
every tuesday a 300 to 500 word blog
post and right when you're writing from
line it should be you know nice and
snapping and bullet points bolt and just
engaging online content i can talk about
this for way too long in it the other
thing you can do is you can brainstorm
ideas just because you're walking once a
week doesn't mean once a week you sit
down and write your blog post go out
take pictures gather content figure out
what you think you want to post about
brainstorm so all sorts of tips you can
do when you're developing your content
and then you got one day week down it's
going great then pick up another one and
then just slowly grow your site without
without it being too much of an
infringement on your life it's it's work
but I do it because I love it I guess
that's the other the other key is if
there is something that you enjoy that
you want to spread the word about then
then that's what you should be writing
about right about what you're passionate
about and then it's not work and that's
that's something else I say all the time
writing is supposed to be fun you're not
having fun maybe you shouldn't be
writing because that's it is we do for
the joy right exactly and one last
question i have is emails which may not
be so joyful but how much time do you
spend on emails cuz i know for us we can
get overloaded with emails and lily
spend the whole day on them do you set
parameters like only from this time am i
going to check email or is it as they
come in are you sort of an OCD like me
who checks that all the time and wants
to keep getting back to people right
away i would love to say I've got the
best system
ever for emails but it's sort of like
spending time on emails for me is like
spending time on social networking you
have to do it you have to commit the
time and what I'll do for my email
purposes is all wake up I'll go through
my emails I'm on a lot of email list so
those all mostly meet the subject lines
and then mark as read or save them if I
think I actually need to read it then I
see what I have to deal with for the day
and then I'll go about my day whatever
it is I'm supposed to be doing and like
i said i'd like to say turn off my email
and I don't check it but I don't want to
be untruthful it's it's really just a
mat it's a it's a 4-hour workweek thing
and I looked at in a while ago so can't
give you the exact but there are a lot
of people who say don't check email in
the morning and i believe the lesson for
four hour workweek is you just do a set
amount of time and you tell the people
who you need who need to hear from you
this is when i checked my email and then
you only check your email at those times
and that way you're not going back and
forth and disengaging from what you're
working on the way I work it with social
networking which I'm a little bit more a
little better at is I get up I'll do my
morning I'll do my post I'll tweet I'll
put it on facebook I poster right out
online for the day I'll see what I need
to go with and then I'll I get something
done and then after I've accomplished
something I'll go and I'll spend another
15 minutes doing my email or my social
networking and I recommend a timer
because timers if you're a writer you
got one tool get yourself a timer
because you can time when you will make
a short amount of time to write but you
can also time the time you take when
you're doing your social networking so
you don't get so off track and it's but
last time you look to the placards
morning
it's three o'clock and ooh why am i
hungry oh yeah six hours of passes I got
sucked into the social networking vortex
but the social networking is important
you have to be online you have to make
your presence known you have to have
conversations in really the best way to
do that is to give yourself increments
of time where you do it when it's not
taking so much from the other things
that you have to do during the day